vou votar ário ó e aí a gente vai ganhar
muito com vocês como está tudo bem
é claro que não porque nunca tá porque
eu saí pra jogar futebol com meus
colegas quando eu voltei minha casa
estava inundada e lembra que todo dia
fala assim não teve tempo de arrumar
minha casa minha casa armado então tenho
que arrumar minha casa mas que são
pessoas assim meu deus não aguento mais
esse quarto arrumado manda chuva nessa
caberlon água através de um lado a outro
não divulgação total a minha casa ó a
meta para pato interesse todo mundo é
mais nem na minha vida que aconteceu em
seu interesse
eu saio na sefaz fazer o nado
sincronizado surpresa não volto
e o pior é que o bagaço
dodó ó paí ó
olha o oeste já vos olha o meu quarto a
vazia no meu quarto está a das compras
que o futebol está em cima da cama é
modo têm noção do que é tudo bem
acordado lado um desinfetante ela a
sensação do mundo é a seguinte dia eu
percebi que eu comi muita merda como
também era bastante e eu percebi que eu
tomei muita besteira eu tô ficando curto
olha só tô ficando gordo gordo pançudo
gordo gordo gordo pançudo beleza
enfrentar na academia e academia do gat
tanto mundo fica de magno
aí eu fui inventar de correr para perder
barriga não cada cinco pás todavia oito
em faro só que eu criei um método muito
bom você emagrecer é o seguinte você
tira uma foto em casa né aí vai correr
durante um mês a cada vez que você for
correr você escolheu a bunda de uma
pessoa que corra muito a missão é nunca
perder aquela bolívia eu sempre fui uma
pessoa que gostar muito de esporte já
fiz academia uma vez também gosta de
gente que se empenha sabe a academia tem
gente vai pra academia só que irá votar
silva academia ativa nem minha tira
fotos boa fase às vezes eu acho que a
rede social ela atrapalha um pouco o
rendimento da pessoa na academia agora
às vezes pode ajudar também é um exemplo
e posta foto no facebook o cara vai lá e
comenta frango do outro dia você vai na
academia com sangue nos olhos ela começa
a malhar horta que é para curtir o nome
dela para a rua curtida duas com tina
compartilhar da minha irmã é bom
compartilhar qualquer força compartilha
às vezes eu acho que até o professor na
academia deveria adaptar esse e cimento
da rede social para poder fazer o aluno
deve crescer
ora mas não faltava tudo o que aquela
corte não é bom quando terá já que ele
não é novo
eu quero eu quero sim eu quero perceber
que está curtindo a média obtida
compartilha dessa pauta traz curtir por
desligar filho da [ __ ] aqui nessa
reflexão onde jackson nova contou
empurra para baixo foi curtida sérgio
postiga olha eu acho que daria certo e
também afirmou que a academia tem um
monte com plásticos lançados oito anos
acadêmico cá quando vai ter que passar
primeiro em um post já tomar a vacina
contra o tétano também é só tem ferro
junto daquele pessoal também ficou
impressionado no primeiro detectado e
mia moleque na academia pela primeira
vez um docinho dinheiro pra vocês eu
também fiquei impressionada primeiro foi
na academia é como se fosse hoje o
primeiro dia que eu vou ter a cada mil
já to atacou um canto da boca ao somar
ao ó também quer muito que pequim irá
focar 19 08 11 a droga pudesse comum do
golfo que tocava e borges e bonito não
existe um padrão de beleza você é
gordinho você é feliz gordin podem assim
não seja gordinha bom cara continua
assim não você precisa em uma onda que
você precisa ter sarados e idosos modelo
mas é sempre bom você cuidar da sua
saúde está ligado mesmo que você seja
feliz gordin se você sair de qualquer
jeito dá sempre o shea cada vez se você
não tá muito muito assunto permanece por
conta da sua saúde me disse você é forte
você gosta de ter um corpo musculoso e
que nada a ver com a sua vida caso você
pode continuar a financiar se tente
falar à rua joaquim vez de ficar muito
feio está balão cara tem gente que faz
fisiculturismo fisiculturismo é um
esporte com um futebol não tem gente que
vive correndo atrás da bola que é um
cara que gosta de cultivar o próprio
corpo eu por exemplo eu não sou gordo e
deixou muito magro mas eu tô com uma
barriga então to querendo tirar a quem
pra outro ficar feliz para outros carros
não pra eu ficar bem comigo mesmo porque
eu não tô me sentindo bem com esse bush
que entregará uma pesquisada no youtube
tal pra ver eu não precisar no youtube
tal pra ver se alguém me ajudava a ter
uma rotina de treino melhor e eu conheci
o canal do anderson o canal do ano é
esse canal aqui eu conversei com o cara
o cara super gente boa me atendeu pega
um texto tinha algumas dúvidas é sobre a
alimentação o treino sabe eu tinha
algumas dúvidas e aí eu comecei por um
caminhão e morreu bem pra [ __ ] eu
assisti aos vídeos do canal do cara tô
aí já está inscrito no canal do carmo
impressionei com a atenção que o cara
teve explicar as coisas então caso você
não precisa querer chamar uma bomba não
precisa no seu já não pensei que ia
ficar maroca não sei o que lá mas caso
você queira cuidar mais de sua saúde ou
ficar com um pouco mais bonito sei lá se
inscreva aqui no canal do ano retribuir
a ajuda que ele me deu aqui tal canal
ele aqui embaixo e aqui embaixo de uma
playlist pra você que tá começando a
entrar na academia está começando a
saber no início medo é que uma playlist
você e clique aqui para se inscrever
clique aqui na playlist pra
indiretamente produzido
o hara deu o doido do doido ou eu não
acredito que tenha saques em agosto
neste vídeo o doutor não falte iniciais
ht ocupa do catar é com ela então
pulando clique em continue a ajudar nós
eu quero que você comente aqui embaixo
que você acha mais estranho é que você
acha mais engraçado na academia
é a primeira vez que tá vendo vídeo no
canal sic inscrever-se aqui segue no
twitter
isso aqui é meu twitter você vai no meu
twitter você me segue aqui aqui embaixo
a descrição do vídeo link na canon é a
lógica do patrocínio de dança câmera
aqui tem meu facebook tem o meu italiano
e tem o meu twitter é só você me seguir
você não com a perda no vídeo é nóis pps
político ea nós